[Music]
>> Hi.
I'm Kelly Freed from the
Microsoft Pix Team.
This is a camera that puts AI
inside so you get the best
photo.
As I move this around, we have a
DNN that's trained to find the
best exposure.
So it works with hardware to
pick the best exposure.
So when I take the picture, then
it takes ten frames, some from
before and some after the
shutter click.
The idea is that it takes the
brain some time to actually
click the shutter.
And so by taking some before and
after, we make sure you get the
right moment.
Then we have live image as well
So it detected that there was
some motion in the image, so we
actually create -- we stitch the
frames together to create a
small live moment.
You can also edit.
So we have face beautification
features that clean up skin as
well as style transfer.
It allows you to add styles
to your image.
And we also have a speed
painting, which paint -- and you
can share either the image or
the painting version of the
image.
And you can download this at the
Apple iPhone App Store.
Or if you're on Android, it
should be coming in beta soon.